[Music]
it is from virtue now that the universal
is to receive its true reality by
nullifying individuality the principle
of the perversion virtues purpose is by
so doing to reverse again the perverted
way of the world and to make manifest
its true essence this true essence is at
first only implicit in the way in the
world only in itself it is not yet
actual and consequently virtue only
believes it this faith virtue proceeds
to raise to sight without however
enjoying the fruits of its labor and
sacrifice for insofar as it is an
individuality it is the activity of the
conflict it wages with the way of the
world but its aim and true nature is to
conquer the reality of the way of the
world
the bringing into existence of the good
thus effected is thus the cessation of
its activity or the consciousness of
individuality what will be the outcome
of this conflict itself what virtue
learns from it whether by the sacrifice
it makes of itself the way of the world
succumbs while virtue triumphs this must
be decided by the nature of the living
weapon weapons borne by the combatants
for the weapons are nothing else but the
nature of the combatants themselves a
nature which only makes its appearance
for both of them reciprocally what their
weapons are is already evident from what
is implicitly present in this conflict
paragraph 383 begins by narrating a
clash or a conflict or at least a
nullification involving virtue and
individuality but by the end of it we
see that what's really going on is a
conflict between the way of the world
and virtue with individuality as sort of
the battleground and what's thrown into
the balance and perhaps the secret ally
of one or both of them so how does all
this play itself out so he says it's
from virtue that the universal is to
receive its true reality we've been
looking for the universal this whole
time
how by nullifying individuality by
nullifying individuality as the
principle the source the origin of the
perversion that we saw in the the
previous discussions the previous
dialectics there's a promise here that
we're going to be able to have something
that's that's that's whole that is
integral that is fixed not like that
previous stuff that we saw out like with
the law of the heart right so he says
virtues purpose is doing what to reverse
the perverted way of the world the way
of the world is perverse because of
individuality and the way that the it
plays itself out even in the law of the
heart we're universality is their right
so we nullify individuality and we'll
sort of turn the way of its world on on
its head and if we do that then we'll
get to its true essence which is Hegel
says that this point is only in itself
it's not yet realized but there's a true
essence within the way of the world
there's something that's redeemable
about the screwed up world even the
social world that we live in so he says
we want to make manifest as true essence
it's it's only implicit in the way of
the world only in its it's in itself
consequently here's where it gets really
interesting consequently virtue only
believes it he's going to talk about
faith
or belief globba at this point and when
we hear that term we we usually think in
terms of religion and understandably so
virtue and religion are quite often
connected with each other even in in
modernity certainly in Hegel's time many
people thought that they are integrally
connected with each other but what we're
talking about here is faith as something
less than or knowledge but we're not
just talking about faith in the sense of
you know a an epistemological
compartment we're talking about a
practical compartment so this is
something kind of similar to when when
William James for example talks about
the you know the will to believe and the
fact that by believing and acting in
accordance with a belief sometimes we
thereby do the things that would be
required in order for us to actually
find out whether there's something more
than just a belief there whether we can
have knowledge and that's pretty
important when it comes to moral matters
like what we're talking about here with
virtue so he says at this point you know
virtue only believes that this faith
virtue proceeds to raise to sight
without however enjoying the fruits of
its labor and sacrifice why for insofar
as it is an individuality here is an
important point virtue can be understood
as like this universal over us you know
thou shalt thou shalt not you know hey
get in line and do what you're supposed
to do quit being a bad boy and almost
sort of like a Freudian super-ego at
that point and that's a good comparison
because what virtue has to be in order
to be effective in order to be actual in
the world is an individuality like I've
already pointed out there's a paradox
here you can only be an individuality
that sac
Feist by continuing to be an
individuality that's continually engaged
and sacrificing itself so it's not
totally nullifying individuality is it
so he says insofar as it's an
individuality it is the activity of the
conflict it wages with the way of the
world its aim and true nature is to
conquer the reality of the way of the
world what does that do that brings into
existence a good he says it is thus the
cessation of its activity or the
consciousness of individuality what is
it that the individuality gets out of
behaving in accordance with virtue it
feels itself in touch with the good the
true the beautiful much as we saw in in
the the stoicism section in the stoicism
and the unhappy consciousness where we
saw a similar foundering on the fact
that we're still dealing with
individuals the individual gets to
ultimately hopefully put him or herself
aside and realize this good that's
that's there within the way of the world
if we can reverse it if we can turn it
on its head so he says what will be the
outcome of this conflict itself what
virtue learns from it whether by the
sacrifice it makes of itself the way of
the world succumbs while virtue triumph
this must be decided by the nature of
the living weapons borne by the
combatants living weapons there's a
conflict here and it's not just that
they armed themselves with something
external to themselves virtue and the
way of the world are themselves throwing
them themselves into conflict with each
other and fighting with everything that
they have or at least it seems so at
this point he says the weapons are
nothing else but the nature of the
combatants themselves a nature which
only makes its appearance for both of
them reciprocally that's gonna be an
issue as well without the way of the
world as we saw you don't have the
origin of virtue right then virtue you
know takes on its own life let's say
virtue as successful
can it remain virtue without the
opposition of the way of the world
that's what Hegel is getting at here so
he goes on he says what their weapons
are is already evident from what is
implicitly present in this conflict I
don't think it's that implicitly obvious
but he's going to specify it a bit in
the paragraphs yet to come
the universal is true for the virtuous
consciousness in its faith or is
implicitly true it is not yet an actual
but an abstract universality in this
consciousness itself it is present as a
purpose in the way of the world as an
inner principle it is precisely in this
determination that the universal is
present in virtue - in relation to the
way of the world for virtue as yet only
wills to accomplish the good and does
not to begin with claim that it is a
reality this characteristic can be
looked at in this way the good and
making its appearance in the conflict
with the way of the world thereby
presents presents itself as being for
another as something that does not have
a being of its own for otherwise it
would not want to make itself true by
conquering its opposite that it is to
begin with only for an other means the
same as was shown in the opposite way of
looking at it that is that it is to
begin with an abstraction which has
reality not in its own right but only in
its relation to the way of the world
in paragraph 384 Hegel tells us more
about this this conflict between the way
of the world on the one side and virtue
although now he's going to speak in
terms of the virtuous consciousness on
the other side and when we see that
virtuous consciousness we can think of
something that is present in an
individual but is by being virtuous
consciousness already more Universal
again remember the individual sacrifices
him or herself to be the locus where
virtue is able to exist is able to take
place and now we're going to see this
play itself out a little bit more
concretely Hegel had mentioned that
what's going on on the side of the
action of the virtuous universe virtuous
individual or consciousness or virtue
involves a compartment of faith of
globba a belief of or if you like trust
right so he says the universal is true
for the virtuous consciousness in its
faith that means that it's it's not yet
realized is true it's implicitly true we
believe that it's true we hope in a way
we are faith extends outward that it's
true but it's not yet true it's not yet
something that we can actually tangibly
touch Hegel by the way is not a big fan
of faith for its own sake he doesn't
think that faith is better than
knowledge or anything like that this is
something that you know as a side note
he's gonna get attacked for from
Kierkegaard right so he says it's not
yet an actual but an abstract
universality
so in this consciousness itself in
virtuous consciousness it is present as
purpose corresponding to that in the way
of the world is what Hegel calls inner
principle so the universal is present in
two ways even though what we've got
going on right here is
is a massive conflict going on between
virtue in the way of the world there's
something in both of them that is
connecting them together in this respect
so he says in the in the way of the
world it's its present as an inner
principle so he says it's precisely in
this determination that the universal is
present in virtue too in relation to the
way of the world this is worth sort of
recalling remember how did virtue come
about virtue didn't pre-exists the way
of the world
virtue comes out of the way of the world
and says no no no - it sees the
perversion involved in it the insanity
you know the dead ends the the ways in
which things don't work out and it says
I can do better than that and I'm going
to do better than that I'm and I'm gonna
make you take that way in the world
we're gonna turn things around and and
make them better
but we've raised this question already
can virtue be virtue without having the
way of the world they're almost like
resistance against it this is a very
important point and and Hegel's just
hinting at this here
so he says virtue as yet only wills to
accomplish the good does not to begin
with claim that it is a reality this
characteristic can also be looked at in
this way the good in making its
appearance in the conflict with the way
of the world thereby presents itself as
a being
for an other as something that does not
have a being of its own for otherwise it
would not want to make itself true by
conquering its opposite so what can we
say here this is why I have this schema
here we have a compartment of faith
faith in what faith in the good then we
have willing why do you need to will
something because it's not yet the case
now put aside the fact that maybe you
will to continue something to be the
case just you know
follow along with the logic here we will
the good and we will the good not just
in ourselves because that's either you
can will whatever you like I want to be
a swell guy
well it's tougher when you're out there
in the world hey that's where it matters
I want to do good in the world Hegel
talks in in terminology that shows us
that this is this conflict what's going
on here this is a beachhead this is how
virtue is doing that turning upside down
the way of the world that we saw I just
talked about in the previous paragraph
it is establishing the good there in the
midst of the world and the world's you
know course the the way in which things
happen it's disrupting it it's saying
we're gonna do things in a different way
here I understand that you know
everybody's got to make a buck and
everyone needs to look out for number
one and you know the almighty dollar you
know and blah blah blah pick whatever
cliches you want but we're going to do
something different here and that's
going to be good and it's gonna be
better because it's gonna be derived
from from virtue it's not gonna be you
know just the same old stuff as you're
doing there well this is where it gets
really interesting insofar as we're at
this point we're talking about something
that's an abstraction something that is
for another insofar as we're talking
about establishing the good as this
ethical ontological beachhead in the way
of the world we're talking about
something that would have substantiality
that's so that would be real that would
be actual we're talking about
realization or actualization but
the question is is this good also for
another Hegel tells us he says that it
is to begin with only for another means
the same as was shown in the opposite
way of looking at it that is it is to
begin with an abstraction when she has
reality not in its own right
but only in relation to the way of the
world once we've established it as an
actuality can't it be independent or
does it have to still exist in relation
to the way of the world
well in one sense it can't exist
anywhere else right it's either gonna
exist here inside the interior t of the
virtuous person which is kind of a no
space at all or it's going to be out
there in the social world in a visible
way and in a manner that can actually be
tangibly experienced you know maybe the
virtue it might be useful to use an
example here maybe the virtue that we're
talking about here is an attitude of
generosity that doesn't look for rewards
and perhaps the way of the world is a
society in which everybody is more or
less on their own and you know you try
not to touch other people's property
although crime does occur then the cops
you know crack down on it think about if
you've ever read read gita Maupassant
stories about france right you know
think about the france of his time where
boy you know you could starve to death
on your own and people might live right
next door to you and not give you a
crust of bread even though they have
more than enough because you are you
know you're on your own you have to take
care of yourself well perhaps the good
in this case is establishing some sort
of charity that goes in and says hey
we're gonna feed you we're going to
clothe you we're going to take care of
you
we're gonna listen to your stories about
how crappy your life has been so that
you can actually get on your feet and be
autonomous
perhaps do the same thing for somebody
else so now it's not just a good that's
being done in one place so it's a good
that can grow right well how does that
start itself out you don't start just
sort of one day waking up and say I'm
gonna start doing some good in that
respect no you're you're aware of the
way of the world and you're like that
sucks I don't want things to be like
that I need to do something that what am
I going to do I don't know let me think
about this and then eventually you start
acting and it starts out without knowing
whether it's going to pay off or not I
mean it could be a total shipwreck it
could be that you put yourself out there
and and put your action out there and
nobody responds to it it could be that
you go and you deal with the poor and
you find out that they are just willing
to suck you dry and take all your
resources and you know roll you and
leave you in the gutter those are
possibilities but you have faith so you
trust in a certain way I'm gonna do this
I'm gonna realize this good and then you
will to do it and then the good if you
you know follow through if you can keep
yourself you know from if you can keep
yourself virtuous and and not stray from
that path and the good is realized it's
realized in relation to the world that
it's opposed to but in which it can be
found like we said as the inner
principle of that world so there's still
a lot more to be unpacked but there we
see in this paragraph there's a lot
going on
the good or the universal then as it
comes to view there is what are called
gifts capacities powers it is a mode of
the spiritual in which it is represented
as a universal which requires the
principle of individuality to give it
life and movement and in this principle
has an actual existence this universal
is put to good use by the principle of
individuality insofar as this principle
lives in the virtuous consciousness but
is misused insofar as it clings to the
way of the world the passive instrument
which controlled by a free individuality
which is indifferent to the use it makes
a bit can also be misused for the
production of an actual existence which
destroys it a lifeless material lacking
an independence of its own which can be
formed this way or that or even its own
ruin
paragraph 385 is going to stress to us
the freedom of individuality and it's
it's very important role I mentioned in
previous paragraphs that individuality
is you might say the locus where we're
virtue in the way of the world are
clashing with each other and in a
certain respect it's also the medium and
in which this occurs as well and so
we'll see how this plays itself out here
Hegel says the good or the universal
that we've just talked about you know
that has to be realized in in the way of
the world and and all of that stuff in
the previous paragraph is the good or
the universal as it comes to view there
now Hegel tells us what that are what
that is are what are called gifts gabon
capacities vague heightened or powers
shefte and we can use other terms for
this as well talents for example right
or you know dispositions or whatever we
like the idea is that each person has
certain capacities has certain
propensity zorp role activities or
however you want to put it right some of
us for example in cuisine are super
tasters I'm not a super taster right but
I I know people who are and what a
wonderful thing that is
other people have great musical talents
I have you know a modicum of musical
talent that I have not particularly
developed but I'm you know fortunate
enough that I can you know play the few
instruments that I play and sing along
and enjoy myself you know I'm not good
enough to play in anything professional
but other people are and that's that's
wonderful right I have it turns out a
capacity that perhaps developed over
time for taking complex philosophical
ideas and presenting them in a way
that's hopefully not particularly
misleading
other people can understand and relate
to like I'm doing here all of these are
capacities or gifts or or powers or
talents or whatever we want them to be
right so we've got all of these and you
know some of these are similar to those
that others have many of them are held
in common but he says this is a mode of
the spiritual in which it is represented
as a universal which requires this is
where it gets really important requires
the principle of individuality to give
it life and movement and in this
principle has an actual existence so we
were nullifying individuality before in
virtue right but you can't really get
rid of individuality from the start
because if you don't have individuality
this remains just ideal and as a matter
of fact it's going to remain just ideal
for some individuality you can never get
rid of individuality altogether because
that is the locus of actuality for all
these sorts of things I mean we can talk
for example you see Plato doing this
quite a bit in his dialogues you can
talk about you know different kinds of
arts right the art of strategy or the
art of medicine or the art of farming or
you know whatever the poet's are tell
all you know there's a lot of debate
about what exactly that is in Plato but
you know it's not as if the art we you
know we do have books and things you can
get a textbook but as the capacity as a
power as whatever it is that's going to
be it exists in an individual Aristotle
recognized this when he said that yes
you know you can have a tech name or you
can have an epistemology but that exists
in a person that exists in an individual
and we shouldn't lose sight of that now
why is that important well that's going
to assume an even more important role
here because there's a the clash that
that we saw before is now happening
in the locus of the individual so
whether we make good or bad use of these
gifts capacities powers talents skills
what-have-you depends on what we're
turning them to how we're using them so
it says this Universal is put to good
use by the principle of individuality
that is a human being a person insofar
as this principle lives in the virtuous
consciousness so what does that involve
virtuous consciousness that does involve
a self-sacrifice that does involve a
recognition of something higher than
oneself one's own drives one owns wishes
there there is something of a negation
of self going on they're part of why
sometimes it's not all that attractive
and why the world could be very
attractive right so he says it's misused
insofar as it clings to the way of the
world so what does this mean that means
that these things
Hegel's tracking and the singular here
he's talking about the universal but he
means these things these are as he says
a passive instrument which controlled by
a free individuality and different to
the use it makes of it can also be
misused for the production of an actual
existence that destroys it we can take
the good the universal and misuse it
according to the way of the world and
thereby destroy that good that we talked
about is sort of a beachhead in the
middle of the way of the world this is
what for example this sort of conflict
is what underlies almost the entire
genre of film noir if you ever watch
film noir movies they're very much set
in the way of the world
they're dark people are you know out to
serve themselves or they've got their
own nefarious purposes like they're
sadists or they want to impose some sort
of code of morality that turns out to be
very cruel or something like that and
usually the protagonist is thrown in
there and he'll be you know some guy and
sometimes there's a female lead and you
know most of the time they've been
following the way of the world and they
had these talents and usually their
talents have been kind of you know
frittered away there but then there's
the possibility do I do something that's
good do I do I through something that's
self-sacrificing
even though that's that's for suckers
that's for dummies well this is the
debate about whether you preserve
something fundamentally good something
free in the world so think for example
about about Casablanca right
what does Humphrey Bogart do he sends
her on her way right he sacrifices for
the sake of virtue and then you know
who's his representative of the way of
the world who's his friend the police
captain I think right or perhaps major
or something like that and they walk off
and I says I think this is gonna be the
beginning of a beautiful friendship
because that's what he's got left right
and we could go on with example after
example and in many of the noir 's the
character doesn't pick the right choice
right and the good is in fact by the end
tragically destroyed so that that's just
a you know little not literary but a
cultural example of what we're talking
about here so he says that what we've
got is a lifeless material lacking in
independence of its own which can be
formed this way or that or even to its
own ruin it becomes very important at
this point to realize that if the
individual is going to take on virtue
it's got to be by the free choice of
that individual not just you know
hearing the message over and over again
and saying okay I'll be virtuous now
because that is just a disguised way of
conforming to a different way of the
world
virtue in the sense that Hegel is
talking about and this is a very
important point involves a freedom that
can give up its own freedom for
something better that it recognized
as better than just its own drives and
thereby it uses these capacities these
gifts whatever it is that it's been
given bestowed upon it developed over
time fortunate enough to to have at its
disposal for the right purpose
you